morning all it has been dubbed a
betrayal of the north and the great
train robbery by the likes of senior
tory mps regional leaders and industry
figures all of them angry that the
eastern leg of hs2 has been axed and a
downgrading of a high-speed rail line
across northern england let's speak now
to the man who unveiled the government's
integrated rail plan at the transport
secretary grant joining us from salford
mr schapps good to see you this morning
morning
clearly an announcement of significance
yesterday but not perhaps quite as
significant as many had been led to
believe can you just explain why the
eastern leg of hs2 is now not going
ahead and why that high-speed rail link
between leeds and manchester similarly
will not be going ahead as promised
uh that's just not accurate reporting
actually uh this is a 96 billion pound
package it's the first time spending
that sort of money it's being called a
robbery
96 billion pounds package it does
include three new high-speed lines
that's from crew to manchester from
warrington across to the west of
yorkshire and a new line
from birmingham to nottingham and derby
so there are three new sections of high
speed allowing there are nearly 400
miles of electrification of line lots of
other upgrades including digital
signaling and actually the thing will
matter to people in the end as if you
are in manchester which is where i am
this morning you'll have a 33 minute
journey across to leeds if you're in
bradford you'll have a 12 minute journey
to leeds so we're talking now about some
really fast journey times due to this
multi-billion pound package
of upgrades and spending and high speed
lines
i i mean i might i might be forgetting
things but the prime minister to my
recollection stood in manchester next to
a train and said i'm going to deliver on
my commitment to that vision with a
pledge to fund the leads to manchester
rouge you yourself at a policy exchange
event six months ago said we are going
to complete hs2 and include hs2 on the
eastern leg to leads those were both
promises made by you and the prime
minister those promises have not been
fulfilled why not
that they're absolutely being fulfilled
first of all we're producing that 30
minutes around 30 minute journey from
manchester leeds or to give you another
example manchester liverpool uh in 35
minutes so we're giving that
interconnectivity we said we wanted to
create that kind of connection that you
would have perhaps if it was in the
south in the north and when it comes to
hs2 we're going to deliver hs2 trains
and look the best way to do that into
leads
the plan for hs2 was conceived 15 years
and more ago and we always said what we
want to do is make sure it actually
integrates with these plans for northern
powerhouse rail which we are building
that is the line which goes across and
including high-speed uh rail which will
make those dramatic journey time
differences um as well as uh midlands
what's called the midlands rail hub uh
the ability to connect the midlands up
much better um so for example you'd be
able to travel from our biggest cities
in the midlands birmingham um say to to
nottingham uh in in under half an hour
that sort of thing so 27 minutes so you
know this is a massive plan it spends 96
billion pounds uh over 50 billion of
that is is is new money into this plan
um and so everywhere no matter where you
are you're going to get uh you know uh
as good or or better journey times
nearly everywhere across the midlands
and north it's really actually and you
are a
you're very free to argue that point but
the level of cognitive dissonance on
display this morning is nothing if not
impressive did or did not the prime
minister say to the commons this year i
can certainly confirm that we're going
to develop the eastern leg as well as
the whole of hs2
um which is exactly what we're doing and
i think it's been misunderstood the way
that's been um uh created so the eastern
leg will be developed as i said there'll
be a new brand new high-speed line i
think it covers about 35
of the distance we'll then look to
utilize and upgrade for example the
midland main line um so if you were
taking the journey to sheffield it will
be exactly the same under this plan as
it would have been under the original
hs2 plan but sheffield and many other
places will be served in between so this
is now bringing in a lot more
communities who wouldn't have had the
benefits of high speed uh with this
measure and as i say there's 100 million
pounds in there not only to look at how
to take trains hs2 trains i should say
into leeds but also
how to give leeds a a a transit system
because that is the biggest uh town city
rather in europe without its own transit
system so all of that and much much else
is included in here and the the only
disconnect are some of the uh complaints
from i have to say largely uh labour
leaders uh who are completely misleading
people because when they actually look
at the list of journey times what their
uh what their residents will see is
they'll be able to get around a lot
faster from virtually every place to
virtually every place
i have to say i think the idea that it's
only labor leaders that have been
criticizing this is similarly white of
the mark minister hugh merriman your
colleague from the conservative party
who chairs the transport select
committee accused the prime minister of
selling perpetual sunlight and then
leaving it to others to explain the
arrival of moonlight at robbie moore
another 2019 or 2019 tory intake
mp he said that the region has been left
completely short-changed ministers need
to do much much more kevin hollandrick
said
that bradford will be paying an economic
price for generations sir edward lee now
describing hs2 as a white elephant
wouldn't it now without a leg i mean
these are colleagues of yours within the
conservative party so i can list
regional mayors as well all of whom who
say that this plan is a retrograde step
namely a city in the north okay well
this is welcoming the changes to the
plans
right first of all a lot of the the
names you mentioned lee for example have
been long-term opponents of hs2 so you
know there are people who you're quoting
and only partially quoting because in
each of those cases they also went on to
welcome different aspects the thing
about rail is uh you know if you if the
train service doesn't come to your
community then quite rightly you will
always speak up about it but for example
that quote about bradford is simply
wrong a 12-minute journey to go from
bradford to leeds 12 minutes this
connects these two great northern cities
up in a way that uh you know
even even towns uh in the south are not
connected up this is far better in terms
of
challenge
let me just finish answering your
questions
let me answer your last question
and said it was
you asked me you asked me the last
question let me answer it name you some
mayors you said you gave me the
challenge yes i was with andy street
yesterday birmingham a big winner in
this nottingham a big winner derby does
very well anything north of that mayor's
uh in in yes of course ben halton who i
spoke to uh yesterday about this is that
hs2 according to ben hodgson is now a
waste of money billions of pounds
but ben hadsham was never in favor of
hs2 it never was going to run uh to
tease valley but what he white massively
welcomes and i don't think we've even
discussed yet is the billions of pounds
of upgrades to the east coast mainline
things like the digitization of
signaling which will mean that those
journey times anywhere up the east coast
anywhere on the east coast even into
scotland will be massively improved by
this investment and really there's the
only disconnect here is 96 billion
pounds being spent virtually every area
receiving as good or better service than
would have been under the original plans
and then uh anyone really saying oh we
don't get anything out of this it's
simply not true you know manchester to
lead 33 minutes i mean that is a huge
improvement from where we are you know
manchester to liverpool 35 minutes these
are massive improvements for where we
are from where we are at the moment and
they complete a northern powerhouse rail
which includes high-speed lights
just to reiterate though newcastle not
supporting it liverpool not supporting
it leeds manchester sheffield bradford
as i just quoted none of them are are
particularly happy with this i mean i'm
speaking last night to the editor of the
yorkshire post who actually carried an
article by the prime minister yesterday
morning i i just don't believe that you
understand the depth of anger that
exists this morning about another u-turn
by this government he told me this this
is a betrayal of the north as severe as
mississippi's decimation of northern
industry in the 1980s
well well look i mean if you are in
newcastle then be aware that uh rather
than taking 81 minutes so an hour and 21
it will take an hour and a quarter to
get from say newcastle to leeds and
that's without taking into account that
the massive advantages of the
electrifications uh further south uh as
well and the digitization so this will
have been the only uh this will have
been the the only uh time in history
where massively improving everybody's
rail services would have been counted as
a betrayal it's a strange approach but
if you live in those areas i urge you to
download the integrated rail plan rather
than listening to what these people are
saying download the integrated braille
plan pages 18 and 19 will list your town
or city and it will show the speed of
improvement for the journey that you'll
now be getting and if you still feel
betrayed by being able to get to other
places much much quicker uh then you
probably will agree with whoever said
that otherwise you'll probably be
grateful and happy that you can get
around much much faster because of this
enormous investment
the the problem though with what you
have just said about ignoring these
people you know
the the reason it's difficult for people
to ignore them is because they've
elected them but just on the the point
of increased
increased speed the prime minister said
yesterday in virtually every station
along the line it's either faster of the
same your own document lists 28 routes
by my counting five have faster journey
times under the new plan four have the
same times 19 have worse times yeah five
of those are within 10 so you could say
that they're similar so just in in terms
of the assertion that everyone along
this line will be seeing speedier travel
and that's just a lie
um i i don't recognize your figures i've
got two pages here you can see i've torn
them out of the
report uh it lists a lot more places
than you just mentioned right off the
bat so i i don't i don't recognize what
you're saying virtually everywhere uh
gets much better services than was
envisaged under the original hs2 plan
which is to say
other than the fact that
obviously ripped through the countryside
there'd be an awful lot of people this
morning who will be uh relieved um but
other than that
there are just massive journey time
improvements and as i say you know a
half an hour or thereabouts journeys
from manchester to liverpool from
manchester to leeds these are real
improvements oh and there's one other
thing i should mention rather than these
being delivered nev in the never never
time because previously these wouldn't
have come about the 2040s these are
upgrades which starting this christmas
and will be delivered in many times many
cases during this decade so rather than
having to wait forever people will get
the advantages much much sooner i do
encourage people to actually take a look
at the document itself because i think
they'll get a very very different
picture i would encourage them to do
exactly the same but can we just focus
for a second on the money and the 96
billion pound figure that that
understandably you're pretty pleased of
isn't the truth of that 42 billion of
that has already been allocated for hs2
from london to birmingham crew so
actually the additional funds that we're
talking about here are roughly in the
the region of 54 billion i think you'd
accept that but actually
about that and we say that in the
document yes great estimates vary but
with the full hs2 and npr network
as you previously promised we were
looking at perhaps as much as 185
billion now you may well contest that
figure but it is a statement of fact
that as a result of the u-turn that you
and the prime minister performed tens of
billions of pounds less will be spent in
the north
there was never a figure of 185 but i do
broadly speaking accept that if you were
to just do everything that everybody has
ever
mentioned it would come to about 185
billion clearly would not be affordable
in terms of other priorities for the
country and whether you'd have to take
that out of health or education or
welfare or something else uh it clearly
would never have been
delivered at 185 billion pounds and i
just want to repeat the central argument
here first of all when you look at the
figures if you wherever you live in the
country if you're in the midlands or
north take a look at what your journey
times will be you'll see that likely to
be at least the same or largely much
better uh than they are today with
really quick journey times as i
mentioned things like bradford leads in
12 minutes which i think people will
massively welcome the second thing is
you won't have to wait until the 2040s
to see these improvements these
improvements uh will start coming much
much faster in during this decade and
again i think that that matters to
people more than some dream of something
which may never ever occur in so many
decades time and as you rightly point
out will bankrupt the country uh in the
meantime
given that both you and the prime
minister have within recent memory
promised that eastern leg of vhs2 which
is not going ahead that new line between
leeds and manchester which is not going
ahead on what basis should we believe
any of the promises that you're making
this morning
okay so we are building just to correct
you again we are building more hs2 line
on the eastern leg so from birmingham
eastwards uh towards nottingham to to
derby by the way unlike the original
plans we'll actually go town center to
town center so those are more journeys
that dramatically speed up they're
actually faster between birmingham and
naughty and birmingham
than you would have had under the
original plans and then with the
upgrades that we're doing the midland
midland main line all across the east
coast the journey times to many of the
locations are identical to the ones that
we would have had uh with uh sort of
full fat hs2 if you like so sheffield
for example in about the same time and
then we are in this plan going to be
looking at studying how to get those hs2
trains into leads so i think you're
you're rather
rather overselling uh that disappearing
that that is still there and we're going
to do all of this much much sooner 10 15
years sooner than the original plan
would have delivered so if you are if
you are a rail user and you are hearing
this argument don't take my word for it
don't take your word for it go and look
at the document go and look at the
journey at times
and you'll see the the massive
improvements which are being provided
minister always good to have you in the
program thanks for your time
likewise thanks
now to return to our top story
representatives of all 18 first-class
counties as well as the england and
welsh cricket board will be meeting at
the oval today in the wake of the racism
scandal that has engulfed the sport the
former cricketer azeem rafiq gave a
devastating account to mps this week of
the racism he endured at yorkshire
cricket club but yesterday he himself
apologized for anti-semitic slurs
contained in text messages he sent
back in 2011. now let's take you through
the timeline of events last year azeem
rafiq made allegations of racism against
yorkshire county cricket club saying it
left him close
to taking his own life
in the same month the club launched an
investigation into those allegations
almost a year on yorkshire received the
findings of the report but did not
release them the following month a
summary of the findings and
recommendations of the independent
report was published saying that azeem
rafiq was the victim of racial
harassment and bullying
yet despite this
at the end of october yorkshire county
cricket club said it would take no
disciplinary action against any of its
employees players or executives
a number of sponsors ended their
partnerships with the club including
nike and yorkshire tea
so senior figures at the club including
chairman roger hutton resigned following
widespread condemnation from individuals
including the prime minister and the
health secretary
earlier this week mr rafiq gave evidence
to mps on the commons digital culture
media and sport select committee uh
let's bring in uh skies shingi maruriki
joining us at from the oval in south
london this morning shinga good to see a
meeting of some significance for the
sport
that's right neil this morning
representatives of the 18 first-class
sides and the ecb will meet here at the
oval they'll be discussing what they
call a one-point agenda looking at
diversity and inclusion in the game but
the pressure is quite clearly on no one
will forget azeem rafiq's testimony
earlier in the week in parliament in
which he spoke about the sport being
institutionally racist that he mentioned
a number of instances in which he
himself had encountered discrimination
but of course yesterday the news emerged
that he himself had sent a series of
anti-semitic messages to a teammate
david in 2011 while later on this
morning to just give you a sense of how
much of this news this sort of news is
emerging alex hells an england player
was pictured on the front page of a
newspaper wearing blackface he says that
that was a tribute to a popular rapper
but he has obviously been condemned by a
number of anti-racism groups already and
all of these things are why this meeting
later on here at the oval matters the
wider culture of cricket is underneath
the spotlight and a number of people
will be calling for the leading figures
in the game to take action to root out
racism as quickly as possible
an independent parliamentary watchdog
says that the government was not fully
prepared for the wide-ranging impact the
covid pandemic had on society the
national audit office found previous
plans that could have helped preparation
weren't properly implemented aisha sahid
has been taking a closer look
seeing friends and family is something
we've all got used to again after the
country stood still for months on end
and these became familiar scenes high
streets were empty shops closed and
classrooms virtual
disruption that could have been
minimized had the government been more
prepared according to a new report the
pandemic really exposed weaknesses in
government's approach to emergencies
like covid19 which are so broad that
they touch on every aspect of public
life
so once government had prepared for a
flu pandemic and an emerging high
consequence disease and was able to use
some of this planning for its kobe 19
response it had not prepared a specific
response for kovind 19.
the government says it always followed
scientific advice
we will make sure the nhs gets all the
support
it needs to continue their brilliant
response to the virus so far
the plan
does not
set out what the government
will do
it sets out the steps that we could take
at the right time
and on the basis of the scientific
advice
our country remains extremely well
prepared
but problems came to light very early on
from shortages of ppe a lockdown that
came too late and an overwhelmed nhs
i wouldn't call it naivety when it comes
to uh not anticipating a pandemic of
this scale in the uk i would actually
probably call it arrogance
i think we felt that we were
so sufficiently prepared and we had such
a robust health system that we could
deal with anything
and to our detriment because i think we
were very slow to lock down because of
that
while the pandemic is far from over
covert 19 has very much become a part of
our everyday lives and with a busy
festive season ahead focus is on what
happens next
with rising case numbers experts have
concerns over what the next few months
could look like but people here in soho
hope restrictions are kept at bay
my main thing is i do not want to be
locked down again
i think it is going to get worse over
christmas but i think everyone's
accepting of that
and we've just got to find a way to live
with it now i think bringing back
restrictions now would be
doesn't make sense based on the fact
that everyone's vaccinated and
hospitals are not buckling like we all
thought they were going to
the biggest question of all remains to
be answered
whether or not lessons have truly been
learnt
aisha zahid sky news
uh some of the other stories making the
news this morning
and two children and two women have died
in a house farm in bexley heath in south
east london london fire brigade says six
fire engines and around 40 firefighters
were called to the blaze last night
all four people died at the scene one
other man has been taken to hospital the
cause of the fire is being investigated
india's prime minister narendra modi
says his governments will withdraw
controversial farm laws that were met
with year-long protests the legislation
which was introduced last year
deregulates the sector allowing farmers
to sell produce to bars beyond
government regulated wholesale markets
small farmers said the changes would
have made them vulnerable to competition
from big business
serena williams has joined calls for an
investigation into the disappearance of
a chinese tennis player pong shui has
not been publicly seen since accusing
china's former vice premier of sexual
assault two weeks ago
chinese state media has released a
letter attributed to miss pong but
doubts have been raised over its
legitimacy
the united states is considering a
diplomatic boycott of the winter olympic
games being held in beijing early next
year this decision would act as a
protest against china's human rights
record including what washington
describes as a genocide against minority
muslims the u.s president joe biden says
the boycott is something he's
considering the transport secretary has
told sky news this morning that the
government will fulfill their promise to
improve rail services in the north now
that's despite the announcement that the
eastern leg of hs2 has been cut back
with the northern powerhouse rail line
also downgraded grant shap said their
promises will still be
delivered they're absolutely being
fulfilled first of all we're producing
that 30 minute around 30 minute journey
from manchester leeds or to give you
another example manchester liverpool uh
in 35 minutes so we're giving that
interconnectivity we said we wanted to
create that kind of connection that you
would have perhaps if it was in the
south in the north and when it comes to
hs2 we're going to deliver hs2 trains
and look the best way to do that into
leeds
the plan for hs2 was conceive 15 years
and more ago and we always said what we
want to do is make sure it actually
integrates with these plans for northern
powerhouse rail which we are building
that is the line which goes across and
including high-speed uh rail which will
make those dramatic journey time
differences
uh let's bring in our political
correspondent rob powell good to see you
this morning rob like if you listen to
that interview with the transport
secretary and phil you'd be forgiven for
thinking that absolutely no promises
have been broken this morning yeah
there's a line in the daily mail this
morning neil saying that grant chaps
could sell sand in the sahara with a
straight face and i think what we saw in
that interview was a prime example
really of doubling down and not giving
an inch
let's be straight what was announced
yesterday is really significant it's a
lot of money and it will change it will
improve journey times it will change a
lot of people's commute
but also it's not what was promised
before because we are not getting new
hs2 track running up to leads grant shap
said in that clip that we're going to
take hs2 into leads at the moment
there's no hs2 track or trains running
into leads it'll stop at sheffield and
there's a study to figure out how to get
it into leads he talked about journey
times virtually everywhere improving
that might be something of a surprise if
you're waking up in leeds or york or
darlington or newcastle this morning the
leeds manchester link will be slower
albeit by the government says a matter
of minutes but even the most balanced of
commentators on this is still slightly
perplexed about how you double capacity
between uh manchester and leeds without
building a completely new track and
running it halfway on existing lines
grant chaps also says that the
disadvantage with the old plans was we'd
be waiting until 2040s for new track
the difficulty with that is that you
look at the government's own plan
yesterday and the hs2 line that runs to
these midlands the hs2 line that runs to
manchester you will still be waiting
until the 2040s for that it's the
electrification work that comes sooner
but even on that that part of the
transparent electrification was planned
anyway the middle and mainline
electrification was canned in 2017 um by
chris grayling so i thought it was an
interesting approach given the scale and
palpable anger from across the board in
the north this morning that grant chaps
this morning uh seemingly refusing that
anything will be less good than what was
promised yeah and chris grayling might
well be looking to see if any royalties
are coming his way after the
announcement yesterday for now though
rob we'll speak to you a bit later in
the program for now thanks very much
indeed
but let's return to cricket and
representative of all 18 first-class
counties as well as the england and
wales cricket board will be meeting at
the oval in the wake of the racism
scandal that has engulfed the sport uh
former cricketer azeem rafiq gave a
devastating account to mps this week of
the racism he endured at yorkshire
county cricket club but yesterday he
himself apologized for sending
anti-semitic messages in 2011 in a post
on social media joining us now the
writer and broadcaster meter goes who is
also the author of an upcoming book
entitled the impossible dream can we
ever have a non-racial sports world may
hear good to see you this morning do
hope you're well
very well thank you thank you um can we
start with with the latest development
in a story that frankly by my reckoning
has been going for a number of decades
let alone months and weeks uh azeem
rafiq apologizing for his own use of
anti-semitic language what did you make
of that
well i think
you know
these things have happened in the past
azeem rafiq himself if you like went
into the past brought out a number of
allegations which have proved as you say
devastating and which of course extend
beyond him and he himself is of course
not blameless and and this past hasn't
been looked at and i suspect but more of
this will come out of many other
cricketers and many other
people in the game and and we shouldn't
be surprised that we will get more
revelations in the in the days and weeks
ahead
um here i will freely admit that i am
not a cricket man be on a couple of
boozy days at headingley and watching
scotland beat england in the one day
world cup my experience is pretty
limited you have spent far more time at
these grounds just how pervasive in your
mind has racism been in cricket
well what's interesting about cricket is
not that the spectators generally are a
problem which is not the case in
football which hasn't been historically
the case football where when i was first
reporting football in the 70s national
front used to be outside the ground
saying get your color supplement and
things like that
what has happened in qriket and this is
the big thing about qriket is that it
has gone backwards in the sense when i
first started reporting quicker in the
70s and 80s cricket was a very very
multicultural multi-racial sport england
was the place everybody came to play
cricket and
viv rich's great friend was ian both him
you know one man from antigua another
man couldn't be more english and things
like that cricket at the at the at that
level and the county level has actually
become very white not a deliberate
policy but because this is how it's
happened and that that is the question
and therefore dressing rooms are very
very white the odd non-white person
stands out and of course remarks are
made and things like that and one must
say that over the years i've heard
cricketers tell me privately of the
discrimination and the racism they face
but they were not prepared to come out
because they were not they were worried
this might affect their career how it
would affect their standing and so on
and so forth and this is the change if
you're like this new generation and who
who've grown up in the last 20 25 years
who feel that they ought to come out and
talk about it so i wouldn't say cricket
is you know absolutely deeply racist but
it hasn't looked at the problem and it
has been self-satisfied there's a
complacency glow about cricket oh we're
all right you know we're doing fine we
don't have any problems with our crowds
and things like that and this is what
what rafiq has done has punctured it
well with a lot of the racism and qriket
then taking place behind closed doors
what hope then for the for the meeting
taking place behind closed doors at the
oval today between the ecb and the 15
first class at county clubs it it
strikes me that this perhaps is that the
start of quite a lengthy process
it is the start of a lengthy braces and
this is again cricket where cricket is
different from football you see the
counties are not self-sufficient without
money from the ecb the governing body
it's not like the premier league which
is which is such a huge money monster
that it can defy the fa if it wants to
the the counties need the ecb money for
for them but yet the ecb has shown no
leadership the ecb kept saying about
yorkshire well let the auction
investigate it you know and the ecb said
you know we saw that the testimony of
tom harrison in the ecb um very pathetic
really in front of the dcms
saying well you know we are the
regulator we can't do it so the ecb
needs to assert itself the ecb needs to
say what exactly it's doing and i must
say though his position at the moment is
is not formally in doubt that there are
questions whether tom harrison can carry
on as chief executive of the ecb because
he's come under severe pressure since
his performance in front of the mps um
at the dcms hearing now the uk's public
spending watchdog has accused the
government of
being unprepared for the impacts of the
pandemic on society a report from the
national audit office says that the
covert crisis highlighted the uk's
vulnerability to an emergency of such a
scale and says that the government must
learn lessons to strengthen national
resilience we're joined now by gareth
davis from the national audit office
gareth very good morning to you and take
us through your findings the report as i
as i understand it identifies that that
this government like frankly other
governments around the world had a
failure of risk assessment
that's right i mean clearly the the same
findings do apply in many countries
around the world um but it's clear that
uh
in the uk we weren't prepared for a
pandemic of of this kind uh with these
kind of effects
and um i mean one of the reasons that's
clear is that uh this is our 23rd report
on the government's response to code 19
and so we've looked at the furlough
scheme the uh dealing with the impacts
of school closures
and across the whole range of responses
but quite commonly one of our findings
has been there was no plan
to to deal with this kind of situation
so there was no plan for
um how to deal with mass school closures
there was no plan for employment support
schemes so the furlough scheme had to be
developed from scratch in just a very
short number of weeks
so
the question that that raises is what is
it about the way that the risk planning
for these kind of events was carried out
that left us unprepared and as you say
really crucial that the lessons are
learned in case of something of this
kind um or some other kind of
catastrophic a catastrophic event that
needs systematic government-wide
planning
what insight then have you gleaned as to
why we were so singularly unprepared for
this for a coronavirus pandemic there
has been some work of course done in the
past on influenza pandemics but of
course you know transmissibility varies
asymptomatic transmissibility is a
bigger issue when it comes to
coronavirus and that was a bit of an
issue of course when it came to our our
strategizing for this
of course and there's also a good
detailed plan for a mother's outbreak
which would be you know a more a more
infectious a more fatal
outbreak of a disease so leading to the
creation of emergency centers for
concentrating those patients and so on
but but neither that nor the influenza
plan turned out to be exactly what was
required in this case and of course this
is all with the benefit of hindsight but
um
but it's really important that that high
insight is used to understand how the
planning system needs to change give us
a better chance of being prepared uh for
for these kind of
diseases it's also the case you know our
report sets out that the number of
exercises that government carried out
and to test its influenza plan and its
mers plan for example uh not all the
lessons of those exercises were then
implemented in in full some were and
some of the reasons we were able to move
quickly was because of those exercises
but there were gaps and so one of our
recommendations is that government has a
much more systematic method of ensuring
that all of the lessons emerging from uh
big exercises of that kind are
implemented across government
on whose shoulders then does blame if
any is to be apportioned
then fall i mean quite clearly you know
since 2005 we've been conducting these
risk assessments is it the cabinet
office is it other senior figures within
the civil service is it ministers
perhaps
i mean this is a system-wide challenge
so and i report the purpose of our
report is not to apportion blame there's
clearly going to be a public inquiry uh
next year
and it's not our job to anticipate what
a public inquiry might find our job is
to accumulate the evidence from our
audit work and to present that in a
factual and balanced way so this report
is part of that effort
um but i think the
in response to your question about where
does responsibility lie it's it's across
the whole system so cabinet office has
lead responsibility for risk management
in government
through something called the civil
contingencies secretariat
that's working hard to understand
exactly these lessons at the moment and
revise government's approach to
enrichment to risk management in a
fundamental way
and our report is designed to assist
that process and to help parliament uh
scrutinize governments work to improve
it
it strikes me then that perhaps dominic
cummings had a point when he identified
the cabinet office and and other aspects
of the civil service of whitehall
are simply not communicating effectively
enough how then in your mind can we can
we learn and move forward and ensure
that there is that cooperative
collaborative effort across government
that you need in the middle of a
pandemic
you really do i mean actually um the
fact that government has had to respond
to this pandemic across all of its
functions and not just central
government but with local authorities
the local resilience forums as they're
called
and
business more widely uh just shows that
this is not something you can contain to
one government department or even
central government so
the first lesson is government becoming
just routinely better at working as a
single entity itself and then with its
partners across the whole system and
we're about to see you know a a slower
burn but but
equally significant challenge with net
zero for example where
the lessons of this pandemic are are
actually relevant to how government
might make a success of net zero because
it requires concerted action across
departmental boundaries with the private
sector and with the public and uh those
are huge challenges which again our
reports are designed to to help inform
well let's hope that they certainly do
gareth davis from the national audit
office thanks so much for your time
thank you
time for us though have a look at the
weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and it's looking to stay mild into the
weekend with rain and gales in the far
north but sunday looking much colder for
now though it is very mild out there
most places dry northern scotland are
wet and windy with gales locally severe
for the northern isles rain and strong
winds will continue to affect northern
scotland through the morning but the
gaels should clear elsewhere it will
remain largely dry if windy in the north
but western hills will be at risk of
drizzly rain
the weather sponsored by qatar airways